joint chiefs chairman mark milley
defends teaching critical race theory in
the military slams offensive claims that
troops are turning woke
and links white rage to the capital riot
now i know it's not the perfect segue
off of you know we were just talking
about but there is this core element of
what's happening to our political elites
our establishment our industry elites
the ideology they've embraced
and this story actually freaked me out
to see joint chief chairman
who's a general mark milley saying that
he's reading mao zedong and lenin
but that doesn't make him a communist
and that
white rage was what caused january 6
essentially
it's offensive to say what did they say
the general appeared to link white rage
to the capital right on january 6.
now that's one of the most the freakiest
things i've seen i mean this is
a non-theistic religion i guess you'd
call it a cult yeah
okay the highest levels of government
can't you just imagine the gunnery
sergeant
did you just make a transphobic comment
soldier that is not my pronoun
yeah how dare you micro aggress sorry i
thought i was supposed to macro
aggression
all right right i have a gun for that
reason but apparently
so i have to wonder about um these are
people who believe there is no truth but
power
they have routinely said there's no
objective reality and
the idea that there is no truth but
power is
i would say to a certain degree there's
an element of truth to it but it is a
very very fascistic ideology
that is being employed by the left when
i say there's a certain element of truth
basically that means
sure if a bunch of leftists have
weapons and are beating you and then
demand you say there are five lights
yeah you can force someone to say there
are five lights but but there won't
actually be yeah exactly
but the history books will tell you that
there were right and that's what that's
what the left has realized
that they can beat people in submission
to just say
falsehoods on the under the and assert
it's true and then they're hoping that
in 10 years
these stories will become history right
well it's it's the left tells us they're
doing this with the 1619 project they
they say
outright this woman nicole hannah jones
lied about her central thesis
but she said yeah whatever i i don't
care about the facts i'm
reframing american history to put
slavery at the center of it
it's very effective to do that and
that's what they're doing now in the
navy this was
the military was basically the last
institution that the conservatives still
had some control over
all of the other ones the media the
schools the
administrative government all of that
had fallen a long time ago and now in
the military you're seeing that
that total infiltration that the chief
of naval operations came out
and he made what i felt was such a
disingenuous
argument to defend all this woke
nonsense in the in the reading list for
the ensigns and the sailors
he said we need our sailors to be
critical thinkers and i think what he
really meant is we need our sailors to
be critical theorists
you do not if you want to be a good
effective military
you do not need to read ibram candy
the idea by the way that the military is
some open free market place of ideas
where
the military literally brainwashes you
that's like the point of military
training
and that but and now they're doing that
in marcusa
and now in all of the people actually
that i talk about in this book
speechless coincidentally
i mean that is the the infiltration that
we've seen in all our institutions
so now it's there and every moment that
they're reading candy and mao
is a moment that they're not reading a
worthwhile writer
you're right the classics right or klaus
fitz or somebody yeah you know we had
bannon the other day and he said we're
winning
we're winning he said he was against all
the you know the violence the capital he
was in favor of the commission
investigating it get to the bottom of
how it happened
because the violence is bad he was like
come august 15th when these kids go back
to school
these moms in the suburbs are going to
explode when they see what's being
taught to these kids
and what they're mandating putting the
kids in the corner make them wear a mask
whatever it is
but i really do think imagine what
happens
when i mean first of all imagine this
you're you gotta your kid just turned 18
wants to join the navy
he comes back to visit you after basic
training and it's like so what'd you
learn and he's like i learned you're an
evil oppressor
white devil they're going to be like
what
basic training but you're supposed to
like be hardened and get in shape
people were so shocked when they or when
no it wasn't even the navy there were a
lot of jokes to make about the navy over
this
but it was but it wasn't the navy it was
the army came out with that ad
yes and they said you know it was that
cartoon of the young girl and she said i
became a strong soldier
because my lesbian moms took me to pride
parades as a kid you think uh okay i
don't know about that
this is not by accident when we can
laugh about it and say oh how funny the
the cia went woke cia's actually been
worked for a long time but the army went
woke
the purpose of this is to attract
leftist people
and to repel conservative people to
finish that infiltration of the
institutions and it
it's obviously working that is a very
dangerous thing because once that one
goes
we're out we're out of the culture
aren't we yeah this is
this is the first time i've really
thought of this is life and death
um for our species if if the
not that the american military is like
the one is like the great protector
there's a lot of
we i have pretty big united states bias
obviously i come from the us i've been
taught
america the us probably maintains the
world pretty cool though and
if it gets uh if it gets co-opted not
only did it lose a war but it's on the
side of that which co-opted it
so it's like double your enemy it is you
know the the critical theory of it all i
know this is these terms get thrown
around now and now the left is
retreating into this nominalism of well
what really is critical theory what
really
but the theory is very simple the theory
is to criticize when whenever
some whenever some reporter tries to
have a gotcha what is critical race
theory what is it
very simply it's to to ruthlessly
criticize all that exists in the words
of marx
so that that's what they're doing and
the idea that we need
deconstruction in the military we need
destruction from the military but we
don't need
deconstruction within the military
that's a recipe for national death which
is probably what they want
i mean physical deconstruction of uh
foreign
military enemies with use of uh
ordinance
yes um philosophical deconstruction of
the
system in place which we use to defend
our country not so much but that's
what's happening but do you know
this i think brings up an important
point for conservatives or even
people who are just not woke who are
kind of normal
the reason they fail a lot of the time
is because they are
arguing in fantasy world american
government
so that when they make arguments about
american politics they're making
arguments about the three branches of
government
and the checks and balances and the
separation and the thing that you
probably are no longer taught in civics
class but you used to be taught
the left is playing in the political
realities where
where are our laws made are they i am a
bill and i call myself you know you're
made on capitol hill and then you
no our bills are made by some faceless
nameless bureaucrat
in some gray building in washington dc
or even outside of washington dc
our laws are effectively made by
oligarchs in silicon valley
as mitch mcconnell pointed out the other
day they behave like a woke parallel
government
the left knows that so they engage in
politics in a much more effective way
because they go where the power really
is not the fantasy of where where power
used to be a hundred years ago